as we mentioned just moments ago
businesswoman tudor dixon was declared
the winner in michigan's republican
gubernatorial primary and that means
she's going to take on governor gretchen
witless whitmer the queen of lockdowns
in november and we're pleased now to be
joined by tudor in her first post
victory
interview tudor congratulations
so excited for you tonight your message
to governor whitmer who's watching i'm
sure
thank you laura for having me just my
message to governor whitmer is families
won tonight families came out and voted
and families want a family-friendly
michigan and we're going to deliver it
and we're going to hold her accountable
to her terrible record here in the state
of michigan we're not going to let the
people forget and trust me as i've gone
around the state they haven't forgotten
now she put out a statement tonight
following your victory
and in it she said tudor dixon has made
clear that she will drag michigan
backwards
and reversing progress rebuilding
michigan's infrastructure and so
distrust in our democracy dangerous for
michigan women and families blah blah
blah sounds like it was written by elon
omar tudor your response
i'd ask families are you better off now
than you were four years ago does she
really think there's any way to drag
michigan any further down than she has
does she really think it's possible for
us to be in a worse condition because
right now we're at the bottom we're at
the bottom in education we have a
problem with cities we need to come back
for safe cities we need to have
businesses have a government that comes
around them that protects them that
wants them to succeed and this is not
what has they have seen for the last
four years but this is what we are going
to deliver to the state of michigan so
my message to gretchen whitmer is watch
out your record
stands strong and it's bad and the
people of michigan want to get rid of it
the only place we're going is up and
we're going to bring michigan back
now tutor you spoke to president trump i
know just a short while ago
come on give us a little
a few little details on what he said
uh he's pretty excited about this race
he said look this has become a national
story you're gonna get this woman out of
there you can go up against her i always
knew that you were the one that could go
up against her and you know what it's
there's something pretty special about
walking off stage with a bunch of people
that have supported you and com came
here just to see me tonight and then
walking backstage and talking to
president trump and having him say
you're gonna do this this is an amazing
night i'm grateful to all the people
here in michigan i'm grateful for you to
have me on tonight just so that i can
talk to everybody and say on national
television thank you so much
tudor dixon this is going to be one of
those gubernatorial races that the
nation is watching
and by the way this caused quite the
commotion during your remarks just a few
moments
a ago business woman and mother and a
far-left birthing parent and career
politician and now we have the
opportunity to truly hold reggie whitmer
accountable for the pain she's inflicted
on each and every one of us during the
past four years
tutor
how are you going to drive that message
home to voters across michigan now women
are birthing parents and men are
birthing parents there's no mothers
anymore in the eyes of the left and
we know uh we know whitmer
doesn't really believe in women and men
anymore she believes in changing all
definitions
well yeah she she's stumbled on what a
woman is she's called as menstruating
people just gross please never call me a
menstruating person we've been called
birthing people you know what moms are
mad that's one job you can't take away
from us whether we adopted our children
whether we birthed our children we are
mothers mothers are going to stand up
for what is right they want their name
back but they also want their kids
treated right so
we are going to go out there like i said
with this family-friendly message and
that's resonating and it's going to
we're going to go across the entire
state of michigan talk to everyone we
can we're going to come on your show
we're going to be out there this is a
national race now when she ran for vice
president it became a national race so
thank you gretchen we will meet you on
national tv
all right tutor thank you so much
congratulations hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else